hello everyone and welcome to the
tiebreaks of round four of the 2019 FIBA
World Cup it's Jeffrey's young versus
young sheet of Duda and two of them have
been battling it out all day well
yesterday and today two of the classical
games they played ended not in a draw
but first do the one with the white
pieces then Jeffrey retaliated also one
with the white pieces then in the rapid
section do that again one with the white
pieces then Jeffrey retaliated with the
white pieces then do that again one with
the white pieces then Jeffrey retaliated
so all four rapid games were drawn and
now this is the blade blade section the
first blade the game was drawn the one
where dude I had the white pieces and
this is double is game where Jeffrey has
the white pieces and if this game is
also drawn then we go into the
Armageddon this is one of the games I
decided to show but probably I'm gonna
show more games from this round probably
tomorrow so without further ado let's
check it out
Jeffrey with the white pieces opens with
E 4 we have Knight to f6 idea in the
defense with E 5 of course advancing the
pawn attacking the knight Knight to d5
and c4 now further harassing the knight
Knight back to b6 and d4 with d6 and
Mount f4 the four pawns attack against
the aliens defense and here the most
popular is just captures on e5 but Duda
chooses in Bishop to f5 we have Knight
to c3 and now e 6i with Knight to f3
Bishop e7 Bishop to e3 and Duda castles
Bishop to e2 young also prepares the
castle into now B captures on e5 with F
captures on e5 and Knight to c6
so all pretty standard in the defense
stuff with castles by Shion
and now f6 this is the most played move
here and this is one of those positions
where it is okay and even the best move
to go f6 you want to get well you want
to attack white strong center but on the
downside after characters and captures
you will now have three point islands
but you you can't have everything
b3 she um now strengthens is a queen
side also he wants to play 21 Queen g3
bring the Queen over to well keep an eye
on the King side also on the c7 pawn he
wants to bring this
broke over to d1 and the position is
very stable with King Queen to e7 by
Duda preparing to bring the other rook
into the game and now Queen e1 as
planned and rook a to D 8 this is a new
move in the position there is one game
where if I was playing but like I said
as of a move 14 we have a completely new
game with rook a to d8 with rook to d1
three attackers to d4 pawn and three
defenders to the d4 pawn and the Bishop
to g4 here Duda attacks one of the
defenders of the d4 pawn but it's not
the greatest of moves young replies with
Knight to e4 and now if Duda continues
with Bishop captures on f3 which
probably was the idea then you get
Knight captures and f6 rook captures and
Bishop captures an f3 and you get this
position where it's equal material but
again Black has three point islands and
well White has the bishop pair against
the knight pair so it's well it would be
a very hard game to play for black so do
the plate h6 here but Queen to g3 going
after the bishop here with the ship back
to f5 and now Knight captures on f6 we
have rook captures on f6 and the now
comes the night to h4
putting pressure on the bishop also the
knight can come to g6 and here bishop
the c2 by Duda and here the best idea
for showing is just rook to d2 pushing
the bishop back and after the bishop
retreats only then do you capture on f6
but here after Bishop to see two young
immediately captured on f6 he played
rook captures on f6 and here dude I just
have to reply Queen captures on f6 and
then the game continues of white has to
decide what's he gonna do with the rook
and so on but dude I said I want to
eliminate you with the black pieces from
the tiebreaks he played Bishop
characters on d1 just grabbing a rogue
they're preparing to capture the bishop
here but this idea doesn't work by Duda
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea for Jeffery
in this position while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent sacrificer of rooks
well and for those
you just want to enjoy the show the
ideas ruk captures on h6 the rook is not
yet sacrifice but this is not what I
meant
you cannot capture it of course as the
Pony spin but after you capture the
piece special capture Sonny - now comes
the move you actually had to find which
is a rook the h8 trick that's the point
now after Cain captures in IG six check
just wins the Queen
you go back Knight captures with check
and after Knight captures you're gonna
capture on c7 the the rook is under
attack the knight is under attack the b7
pawn is under attack your d4 pawn is
nicely protected so this would be
winning for white and on the other hand
after this rook to a trade check if you
don't want to capture the rook if you
want to play King to f7 instead then
just Queen g6 is mate in one so there's
that so rook captures on h6 incredible
move but Geoffrey missed it he played
rook to g6 he prepares this pin and now
he's gonna capture on h6 and here Duda
do that has a couple of moves he would
play of course now capturing the bishop
just runs into Bishop captures on h6 now
you're not getting away from row
captures and g7 but do defines the
absolute best defense resource Knight
captures on b4 and now of course if you
continue with the plan just Knight
captures a need to check wins the Queen
so you have to worry about that with and
of course you don't want to give up your
dark square Bishop that's a very
important attacking piece so brush up
the d3 getting the bishop out of the way
still keeping your eye on the e2 square
and still nice the e2 check you don't
need another attacker here so Bishop
characters with Bishop captures and now
comes in Bishop captures and h6
preparing rook captures and g7 and there
is only one good move for Duda in this
position to get out of this mess so feel
free to pause the video here and now
well one of the rare occasions where I
will ask you to find a defensive move
again you will have a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being such an
excellent defender of hard to defend
positions and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy the show Queen the c5 check
and now the point is well these
diagonals are covered you can either go
back with the King or well you don't
really have a lot of other options you
can go back or you can block a Bishop e3
Queen e3
and and such problem is if king h1 then
rook to d1 leads the mate you have to
block with the Queen and now just rook
captures anyone is made on the other
hand after this Quincy five check if you
try blocking with the bishop then you
still get rook to d1 check and after
King to f2 now you get Queen to f8 check
and now there's a problem because the
bishop is blocking the e3 Square from
the king and here you would just have to
retreat stop the attack because if you
capture the bishop then you get Queen to
f1 again mate so like I said after Queen
c5 check you will have to block with the
Queen and then just Queen captures you
you know eliminated any danger Bishop
capture scheme to have seven and the
game continues however after this Bishop
captures and h6 move Duda did not find
Queen to c5 check he played the rook to
d1 check immediately
the idea is seemingly the same
especially with the clock ticking in a
blitz game but it's not she only played
King to f2 and now Queen to f8 check
again hoping for King captures on E -
and then Queen can come to f1 but just
Knight to f3 and you still have this
problem of rook captures and g7 you
still haven't prevented that and the
only way to prevent that was Queen to c5
so here Duda had to go back he played
rook to d7 okay the g7 point is nicely
defended but now Geoffrey just picks up
the free piece King capture Sonny - so
here I Jeffries up a piece and he still
has a lot of pressure along the G file
with King h7 now unpinning but here
comes Knight to g5 check and here again
the problem is if you capture the rook
Knight captures on e6 this covers a
check from the Queen and wins the black
Queen on f8 so after an IG 5 check Duda
played King h8 and here we have Knight
characters on e6
attacking the Queen with Queen to f5 now
and here comes virtual captures on g7
with check it doesn't help you if you
capture the bishop so King to g8 by Duda
and now Bishop to d4 check opening up a
discovery here King to have seven and
now of course you all see the move King
rook to f6 check check the King picks up
the Queen or if you would trade well
then it's just winning for white so it
was in this position I moved 30 to that
young shift of dude that resigned the
game and as this is game 8 and the
previous game in the blitz mini match
was drawn this means that Duda is now
eliminated from the feed at World Cup
after after an amazing feat after he
started with a victory in the class
full-time format which is really insane
Jeffrey bounced back and it seems that
two of them are really on par with the
white pieces just you know win for win
for win for win for win and then do the
mist is win in the blood section section
with with the white pieces and Jeffrey
did not as you can see he both of them
are extremely deadly with the white
pieces or you know maybe you could say
that they are not as great with the
black pieces but I think they are I
think they're just much better with the
white pieces so here of course once you
trade as there is nothing else to do
Queen captures Bishop captures King
captures you're gonna capture and c7 and
of course a queen and the night are
better than a look and the night so yeah
tough break for Duda but Jeffery
continues and advances into round 5 of
the Phaedo World Cup where he will await
one of the one of the also winners from
their section so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and now I will show
at the standings well those those who
advance to the next round so for those
of you who are not interested in that
maybe wanna skip or or you know pause
the video or something but as I don't
know if I will be showing any more games
from this around I think I will but just
in case so here are the standings as you
can see bingler and eliminated kiddo
like saying home and he meets Alexander
Grisha who was able to defeat a linear
Dominguez so gonna be a really amazing
the next round
Nikita v-cube of eliminated Wesley so he
will face you yongi Jeffrey shank now
who eliminates the youngster Duda will
face Tim or a job of incredible but
steamer eligible eliminated chakra
mamedyarov
so the Azerbaijan brawl ended up in
Timor favor and the maxime beaugeois
Grove who eliminated Peter Svidler will
face Levin Aragon who eliminated
electron beam so it's interesting that
11 Aragon and Dingley Ren are still
going at it
at the World Cup as you know in the
previous World Cup two of them won won
their places into the feeder candidates
tournament so it's gonna be really
amazing give the two of them can pull it
off again sir
that's that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Ravindra yo clicker camels up cove ski
Mathias craft a failure and Souter and
Allen broom for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video Sarah think all for
watching and I will see you soon are
continuing the coverage of the feeder
World Cup and checking up on your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Sunday